we'll we'll start by this by actually um
looking at addressing some of these
cyber security challenges that we've
seen that have come out of this open um
source software security report
in order to start that one of the things
that um i think makes sense to actually
give a little bit of background um how
did this uh security report come about
what
some of the steps associated with it um
steve being one of the co-authors as
well as sneak
the research behind it started back in
in march 2022 and actually this state of
open software security report is
something that's an annual report that's
been going on since uh 2018 here at
steam
started the research in march um as part
of some of the background for that
research to leveraged you know across
the industry did a uh
quite a few of you know 15 different
interviews with open source maintainers
cyber security experts to make sure that
we were asking you know some of the
right questions in order to extract a
lot of the data that we would see is
useful
launched the survey in april and then
that brought us to where we are today as
part of that survey
we did target a few different audiences
across different types of organizations
sizes scopes looked at open source um
software maintainers contributors to
that occasional contributors even some
of the developers as well as consumers
of um the open source software within
the software supply chain
as part of that there were over 550
responses um and then again they went
across many different sort of ecosystems
and backgrounds
so without further ado let's actually
jump into
some of the details of what we saw as
part of this
um in this um what we have seen and some
of the things that we were able to drive
is that the open source security is it's
still a significant challenge right and
and as part of what we're seeing is the
software supply chain it seems to be
growing in complexity
of not only controlling and adapting to
what you have but also with the growth
and adoption of applications uh we're
seeing it become a much bigger sort of
focus as well as a little bit more
difficult to um to tackle
one of the ways to actually make this
session just a little bit more
interactive i think we'll we'll
pop up a poll real quick and get
everyone's insight as far as
if you start looking at um you know
within your organizations if you
interact with those understanding what
what your confidence level is and
understand the risk associated with
direct dependencies uh these are the
dependencies that your developers bring
in directly right listing them
specifically out saying we're building
this application with these components
and then in conjunction with that um
also asking what your confidence level
as far as the security of what are
called indirect dependencies and so for
those of you that may not as be familiar
with some of the development the process
and when you look at open source
when developers bring in an open source
package
inside of that package very often are
are nested or or references to other
open source projects and so you get this
package a that might be leveraging
another open source package b which then
might be leveraging c and d and you get
this hierarchy associated with it those
lower level ones are very often referred
to as indirect dependencies or
transitive dependencies so
understanding the security risk
associated with that is is what we're
looking for as far as feedback in this
poll
excellent so as everybody fills that out
i'm going to transition and we will
start
talking about some of the insight
that was captured
as part of the open source security
uh report
as as part of understanding those direct
dependencies in those open source one of
the things that we were able to gather
from some of the survey results were
that
the average open source software project
on average has about 49 current
vulnerabilities and this also spans
across
79 of those direct dependencies that i
look now that varies across ecosystems
and what you're seeing are some of the
survey results on the far right um and
interestingly enough too
um
the the
vulnerabilities associated with you know
when it says that 49 vulnerabilities
across those 79 direct dependencies
another stat that was actually surfaced
inside of this report mentions that 40
of those those 49 actually happen to be
inside of the direct indirect
dependencies of those transitive ones
that we talk so
knowing that there is this wide spectrum
of
dependencies indirect dependencies met
steve i'd love to get some of the
insight as far as
do you see this you know as as
organizations grow applications as you
know this digital transformation is a
big focus across the ecosystem you see
this is as growing in use um staying
about the same you know kind of what
some of the insights as far as what
you're seeing is as important takeaways
from some of these stats as far as the
the prominence of of these components
so i mean i i think you know it's kind
of probably uh an important point to
make here that that
um
dependencies aren't bad right by by the
definition you know this is what has
enabled
uh
modern software development right so we
don't reinvent the wheel all the time we
have these gigantic um
uh
resource pool of free and open source
software that we can build on top of and
that that's really what's enabled open
source software to
uh to become ubiquitous right so i mean
dependencies you know are not
necessarily a bad thing and i mean you
know
i fielded a couple of questions around
this particular set of stats of like
should i be considering not developing
any anything in javascript right which
is you know it's clearly
you know
not not a uh not a thing that um
that uh
that i think this report is saying so i
think you have to take some of this
stuff in the context of what these
individual ecosystems you know
what they look like when you when you uh
when you
work within them and you know javascript
tends towards a model of things that are
very small much smaller scoped but a lot
more of them you know there tends to be
a lot of choice and a lot of projects
that do a lot of packages that do one
particular very small thing whereas you
know python it tends to be for each
function there will be one
leading package and that package may
have a much bigger scope so
um i think that's kind of important to
to understand um the indirect
dependencies issue you know is really
the the the critical piece here that you
know
um
organizations need to understand what
the
by
using uh this model yes you can develop
software very quickly but you're also
potentially pulling in code that you
weren't aware of you know that whilst
you may have been aware of those direct
dependencies the indirect and you know
down uh along the chain you know make a
as you know from from what we do at
sneak every day you know these these can
be uh
can be very deeply nested you know uh
dependencies and uh four or five plus
levels deep and often that's where some
of these issues in uh in the software
supply chain can come from
i mean one of the things that occurs to
me with in looking at the slide is that
uh this is really a great advertisement
for why software billing materials are
important
and the reality is is that you know we
need knowledge about what's in a
component
we need to understand
how usable it is whether or not we're
licensed to use it or not
and we need to be able to trust it so we
need to be able to have ways for the
actual component and the information
about the component is non-falsifiable
so we can trust it so uh when you get
into dependencies of dependencies the
transitive or the indirect ones
um
things can get very complicated it's
very hard to potentially always you know
have information at your fingertips that
will tell you about the usability and
the trust and and the actual metadata uh
describing the components so so this is
a it's a great reason to take s bumps
very seriously
um because that is probably one of the
best ways to be able to address uh the
complexity that's is as matt was saying
as part of modern application
development
totally agreed and and i'm actually glad
that you mentioned the the the software
bill of material because i think that's
a core component that goes hand in hand
with a lot of this understanding and
being able to
know where these risks are and be able
to then take action upon this right it's
it's not only you know for
sharing externally in a lot of
circumstances where we're seeing some um
governance being dictated also just for
internal use and consumption i think is
a critical element making sure that you
understand the president
i think that actually is a good
transition to start to talk about
what we also what was also
captured as part of this
survey results where that you know as as
as we've seen this focus and there's
some some great examples we'll talk
about a little bit about um open source
and open source risks and
larger sort of consumptions and as we
just saw the amount of projects that
were being used and leveraged and where
some of those vulnerabilities are one of
the things that also was starting
i think was was fairly apparent inside
of these security uh results is that
there's still a struggle i think within
a lot of organizations to prioritize
open security like how do we make it a
core component and when we started to
look at one of these themes and some of
the the details behind it
what we
were able to capture what what what came
out of this was that you know looking at
these real results only forty nine
percent of organizations
currently have a security policy that
addresses open source software and so
looking at you know both the size of the
companies as well as you know who of
those said yes we do and no we don't or
don't know it's intriguing to see even
as you go across like again you kind of
understand that for um smaller
organizations right because there's
there's not um as big of a prominence of
security teams and the ability to to
address all of those but you know as you
start to look at larger enterprises to
also see that you know there's um close
to
30 percent almost 30
um of those some of those very very
large organizations and you know 20 that
still don't have open source security
policies in place um it's interesting to
see that some of these organizations are
still you know struggling with that or
going to that that path and so this is
also another one where i think it's
great to get some insight on as far as
what what you see you know matt steve um
as the impact of that right you know
some of these organizations that are
easily don't have one currently are
still struggling to to actually get one
in place and what what the impact inside
of their organization might be and other
things that should be considered as far
as not having as part of a security
policy yeah this uh this question and
the responses to it was was one of the
one of the bigger disappointments to me
um when i went through and analyzed the
data
on an overall level
the right-hand side of the screen is
absolutely correct we had only 49
percent of organizations had an oss
security policy
we also had
let's say 34
that didn't and then we had 17 that
didn't know
and if you uh take out the don't know
not shores at this point um which can be
done uh from the standpoint of doing
analysis it ends up being about a 60 40
split 60 have a policy 40 percent don't
have a policy that 40 percent is a
really large number um as far as what
the impact of this can be
i think it all comes down to governance
risk and compliance
if you don't have a policy
let me back up just to say
not having an open source software uh
security policy is a little bit
different than not having a software
security policy and we have we didn't
have a question uh the higher level
question which was do you have a
software security policy in place and
i'm going to do that next time around
this was specifically open source i mean
in some ways i would think that if you
had a overall
software security policy in place
the incremental step to have an open
source one wouldn't be
too much of
an effort
um but this is still
being debated quite a bit inside of
linux foundation so we can't presume
anything at this point um but the
reality here is that even with 49 that
don't have an open source security
policy in place
how do you really how do you address
governance risk and compliance issues i
mean you can't effectively manage risk
you don't really know enough about what
you're going to do when it comes to
vulnerabilities
so your security posture suffers
mightily your the quality of what you're
producing can suffer
and this shines a bright light on the
fact that
uh wildex foundation already has courses
in training and certification on best
practices for secure software
development notice we didn't even say
open source secure software development
and it's about 150 best practices and
you don't have to you know eat them all
at once
they're tiered and leveled silver you
know silver
gold and platinum i think
but the reality is is that if you don't
have a policy in place you're probably
addressing best practices for doing
secure software development in a very ad
hoc kind of random way
and policy is one of the best ways to
not only
get organized from the standpoint of
understanding what's important about
security but then making sure you're
addressing it but also taking the next
steps beyond that with things like um
scalability and automation
so i
co-opted the uh
the platform here matt do you want
anything to that
i mean i i think there's a couple of
interesting things to me from from this
stat i mean you know clearly
that you go into a question like that
thinking that you know small
organizations are going to struggle more
with kind of policy driven um
with policy driven stuff around
you know the more challenging aspects of
security so
that's somewhat unsurprising that that
split i think the uh the the fairly
large um
uh sort of uh cohort of larger
organizations there is the one that's
that's really quite surprising
and
i think there's probably a couple of
different things going going on there i
mean you know
most larger enterprises are you know
have some challenges around um
you know making change can be difficult
from a cultural perspective you know
clearly dealing with with sort of open
source software development is a
uh is a different kind of uh security
approach to the sort of things that
we've seen you know over the last 20
years so you've kind of got that inertia
in larger organizations that can be uh a
factor there
and um and and i guess you know
it probably says something about some of
the perceived challenges about putting
in place a policy you know what should
be in a policy about open source right
and i mean unless you've got a fairly
good understanding of of
what are the things that you need to be
thinking about around open source
software um you know then formulating a
policy becomes more difficult i mean as
steve has pointed out there are a lot of
resources out there um templated
policies on this kind of stuff available
from from the linux foundation and from
others but i think it definitely
highlights that that organizations find
it a challenge and you know for for
it it's not just about the code when we
when we talk about about risk or an open
source software either right because
we've got to think about um governance
models you know is that software well
maintained is there a single maintainer
who's going to go rogue and you know as
we've seen in the some of these recent
kind of ransomware things
and um you know how do we identify
what what are the
the uh the sort of uh positive elements
that we should be looking for within a
particular piece of software and that's
not just about function you know it's a
wider thing so i i think there are you
know
a lot of challenges that organizations
face when starting to think about this
thing but
i mean
having a policy is kind of even if the
policies are one-liner right it's got to
be better than zero policy because you
know at least it proves that you've that
you've started to
uh to think about what the issues might
be whereas if you don't have any kind of
policy in place you're effectively
flying a plane blind and you know one of
the other things that i think uh you see
in uh in the wider report is that
there's a pretty strong correlation
between having an open source policy and
your confidence in
the security around your open source
software you know so whilst having a
policy is not a proxy for for for
security maturity you know i mean who's
to say what what's in a policy you know
in in a survey but you know there's
certainly a strong correlation there in
sentiment right steve yeah absolutely
true
yeah i would agree and i think that's
one of the things in the uh we're
obviously not going through everything
that's that's in the report because
there's quite a bit of information
that's covered in there but i do know
steve that there's a lot of cross
referencing as far as you know having
security policies in place and looking
at security postures and confidence in
those security postures and so it's it's
interesting to see some of the
correlations that can be derived when
you actually start to cross-reference
those yeah i mean
just uh just to explain that a little
bit further throughout the report
since i did mostly analysis behind the
survey data one of the things that i did
was to display
most questions segmented by do you have
an open source security policy or do you
not have an open source security policy
and the differences typically are quite
striking um so that really makes the
makes a strong case for having an open
source security policy
agreed
awesome and as as we start to look at um
ones with those open source security
policies or even organizations that have
started to take some sort of proactive
ways of actually looking at the security
posture with those open source um
packages there were some interesting
sort of information and data that was
shared across the approaches that we're
seeing across the organizations like
what are they actually putting into
place as far as the ability to
look at that security risk right some of
the things that are being utilized today
now i know some of these buckets
potentially um group together and
package some of those details but what
we did see is that you know at least 44
of of companies have some way to
you know examine the source code to look
for a lot of those risks and see you
know a couple of different approaches in
here um across you know sort of the
spectrum
with that said obviously again knowing
you know steve matt your backgrounds the
interactions you do equal with all of
these organizations and heavily in
involvement in the in the developer
community
love to get again some additional
insight as far as what you're seeing and
how they align with the information that
that we were able to derive or steve
that you were able to derive through the
security report and kind of how that you
know maps back to some of this data here
well i think um i mean just starting
from the left there's two things i think
that are important that i'm that i'm
going to discuss well the first is
on the left here the 44 percent who use
tools to examine source code
um i counted about 10 or so different
tool categories
uh when it came to tools for helping
address
security
and this would be across the life cycle
of the application now most of these
tool categories had to do with cicd type
activities so very much focused on
development but not all of them
but um so i think the 44 doesn't mean
developers are out there using ides to
kind of comb through their code uh maybe
one of the four eyes kind of uh approach
uh to check to check it because that's
just a very grossly inefficient way to
to do some sort of uh
evaluation of your code base um but
there are a tremendous number of very
good tools out there
to be able to that that need to be uh
used and i think we'll probably have a
slide on this later but the popular ones
are of course are sas tools for static
analysis
uh for security testing and then sca
tools um you know for looking at uh
license compliance and vulnerabilities
so those are those are two great
categories but i think we should lose
sight of the fact that
in the survey results infrastructure as
code iac played incredibly well from the
standpoint of
people using it to help deal with
security and you're probably wondering
well you know how does iac do that
well it's primarily the fact that iec is
very good at automation and if you're
automating activities across ci cd
um that's removing manual touch points
and those manual touch points are where
shortcuts can be taken and introduce all
sorts of security risks so that was i
think the storyline behind iac
and then the best tools
for dynamic
application security testing um
did not
play as well as i had hoped
and i don't i think organizations
shouldn't lose sight of dast
mostly because
that's a very much a runtime focus
and that's an important
way to be able to make sure that you
have better coverage across the
lifecycle
i think one of the things that was that
was positive to me about these numbers
are you know
particularly um some of these some of
these categories uh
slightly down from the top you know
about checking that the uh the project
has an active community looking at the
frequency of commits and releases you
know that
this is clearly uh you know indicating
that people
uh who are answering this particular
question do have an understanding about
those those things that are important to
consider above and beyond the the actual
code within open source projects so i
think that was a that was a uh a a good
thing to have to to to see in this in
this particular graph yeah when it comes
to the adoption of components for use in
code i think many of the responses here
are essentially saying listen we need to
look at the community that is actually
responsible for the component and have a
sort of a have a good sense of how they
function and whether and how they
operate um but i think many of the
responses here are exactly that
yeah and i think i mean what we're
starting to see across the industry is
uh
new ways of providing that information
to
uh consumers of open source software you
know i mean
we start out from things like github
stars but i think now we're starting to
get you know a lot better at uh you know
if we look at the the open ssf
scorecards project you know and and uh
you know
sneak advisor is obviously a free
service that we provide
that give um potential users much more
detailed insights about not just the the
vulnerabilities that exist in that code
but about you know these other factors
you know does that does that uh project
have good governance does it you know
does it have the the right things that
need to exist in that repository to to
give you confidence that the maintainers
are
actively considering security as part of
their software development process
yeah i'm glad both you mentioned that
because that was the one thing i think i
derived from this was more of the
approaches to identify trust right like
building on a like a full framework
associated with you know how do we
actually we we want to leverage this
open source it's a big prominent part of
organizations and building you know any
sort of modern application
and in order to do so there's got to be
this sort of measurement of trust in
order to understand what that is and
using sort of multiple pronged
approaches in order to validate that and
steve you both mentioned this right like
looking at the community understanding
if it's active look at the repetition of
the maintainers and some of the details
how active is it when it is what changed
last and understanding sort of a broader
spectrum uh associated that i think
becomes a critical part of that that
security posture at least from a
proactive perspective yeah i mean it's
interesting how this has changed over
the last 20 years you know this is this
idea of maintain a trust is is something
that's you know it it it's been talked
about for a very long time in in open
source communities and you know
as as communities have scaled you know
there was a time when even in large
projects that every maine to every
contributor knew every other contributor
right i could certainly remember even in
even the bigger projects where where
that might be the the been the case you
know 15 20 years ago but clearly that's
not the case anymore and you know i i
mean
as we start off saying you know we tend
to find these these vulnerabilities in
smaller projects anyway where uh you may
not know who the maintainer of that
particular project is but yeah trust is
is what it comes down to at the end of
the day right
yep
excellent so now let's let's let's
transition over into i'm sure you know
everybody's favorite topic um which
which um became a very prominent um
discussion track the end of last year
which was the log for shell
vulnerability um the one that originated
in
open source and so looking at some of
the impact on understanding um some of
the relationships and a lot of the
things reiterating i think a lot of the
points that we've talked about which are
also very prominent inside of the report
there's a couple of interesting
statistics um and data points that i
think were able to be shared which was
when we looked at log for shell um it
was that you know and again some of this
space upon you know sneak
being in this market being able to see
you know massive amounts of projects and
understand you know the implications of
of customers that were impact that 79
percent of projects were actually
affected by lag for shell and matt i
think you you even mentioned earlier
some of that ubiquity associated with
open source and how they're becoming
very common sort of components inside of
you know a lot of major applications
this being a perfect example
take that and also you know compound it
hand in hand with the fact that
when when we we looked at the open
source you know the log4j component
um
60
of the
instances of those uh those open source
packages were actually in indirect
meaning they were intransitive which
could be you know several layers deep
being used and consumed by other sort of
core components and so i'm interested
again to hear you know matt and steve
your perspective on
what did this mean like what what would
what did you see as far as the impact
you know and i know a lot of us were
involved very closely with you know
talking with organizations walking them
through helping them um be able to
address and remediate a lot of these in
a very very fast time frame but you know
knowing sort of all of these the this
data about
how prominent it was and then also the
fact that it existed multiple times and
sometimes you know buried several layers
people what sort of that um
what what what
organizations had to deal with at the
time of this this you know making the
headlines
i mean this is kind of the perfect storm
right i mean and this is this is the
kind of story that that that you know
happens every couple of years and you
know it brings this it brings this right
to the forefront of people's minds you
know log4j incredibly well used um piece
of of uh utility software to add logging
functions to to to java uh programs and
you know therefore it was being used by
you know a
enormous spectrum of the the all of the
java code that was you know that exists
in the world um and
i mean
the the on the one hand you know that's
brilliant that the the such a piece of
software exists and it's fantastic
utility and you know means that people
don't have to reinvent the wheel but
when you
when you do have uh a vulnerability in
in uh something that's this widely used
then you know clearly the impact of it
is uh is is is very
uh widespread
and um
i mean
the actual vulnerability had been in
log4j for several years right i mean it
was a very small programming mistake
uh and uh
it was only when when someone worked out
how you could actually exploit it that
it even became an issue right so um but
but uh yeah i mean this this kind of
illustrates
i i guess what we're talking about this
idea that uh you know
open source projects can be a victim of
their own success and and and i think
that uh when you have infrastructure
software you know scaffolding software
that's that's in a enormously wide uh
range of things the impact of uh of of
issues being found with that can be
gigantic and i mean this is still going
on right we were talking before we came
in
about the amount of embedded uh the
amount of java programs in the embedded
space where it's incredibly hard to
change it right it's it's flashed into
the hardware you know that that's uh
that's all still going on so
i i think it definitely sharpened
people's minds about the need for
uh software composition analysis
scanners right i mean you know we
certainly
saw a a very large uptick in in
in usage of snake
tied directly to
um to organizations trying to solve this
problem because
you know
people just didn't know whether they
were impacted by it or not because you
know
they've got you know big enterprises
java is an incredibly popular language
you know i've got 10 000 business
applications running inside my
organization i mean that's panic time
right
yep
anything else
deep sorry i was going to say
realistically you know sca tools are the
only way that you can crawl across a
entire portfolio in an automated way to
be able to understand what the you know
what the impact is going to be
when a
building like this is found yep
i think it also like it and kind of
beating the same drum that we have
before but it starts to reiterate um the
importance of some of those open source
security policies um because without
some sort of plan in place when
something like this does roll along you
know the ability to actually react right
to take action to have sort of the
components in place in order to have
some sort of structured mechanism to say
okay what do we what do we do all right
what what what's the next steps
we need to know where we have this you
know
where what we need to do and actually go
down the path of remediation and you
know the steps to actually fixing all of
those issues when they're when they're
discovered
uh and you know you've got you've got
absolutely no way of knowing
you know if it's if it's down your tree
of indirect dependencies i mean it's
it's it's okay if it's in your direct
dependency you can do a virgin bump
you know but how do i how do i deal with
this thing that's like five levels deep
and
you know you've got all of these
dependencies that all need a version
bump in order to in order to uh to to
get rid of that one so yeah
yeah the chain reaction definitely was
was caused by by that um that discovery
yeah i i don't think this is you know i
know this is probably a uh a slightly
controversial statement but i think
sometimes you need things like that to
happen in order to drive change right i
mean i i think you know
he
that's definitely like i said sharpen
people's minds about
you know that you should have something
in place to to be thinking about this
and and to be concerned about it
and without that you know you may not
have had as much change as as i think it
it's driven in the last few months
yeah it's it's a valid point the best
way to know how to prepare for a storm
is to live through a storm so i i i
don't necessarily disagree with that um
so
building on this right like as as we
start to
discuss a lot of these statistics that
were captured um in some of the
information
what one of the other themes that we we
saw was the fact that finding
a solution for this right a complex
solution for a complex problem um was
one of the other i think key takeaways
that that was shared inside of this
report and one of the other more
interesting ones and i know again you
know as as we were discussing this
earlier is this is one of the
interesting statistics that that what
came out of the um the survey results in
that the fact that the time to fix
vulnerabilities um since you know since
we go back a few years and when we
started originally publishing these
reports you know it's gone from 49 days
um to
to now 110 days so a fairly
substantially increased you know over
over you know a span of three years and
then um one of the other things that was
also kind of intriguing is looking at
the fact that fixing vulnerabilities um
takes you know almost 20 percent longer
than fixing
organization's own first party
proprietary code
um i know some of this and i i'm going
to turn it over to you and stephen met
because i know you definitely have some
insight as far as the the stories behind
it but there was there was also an
interesting statistic that was shared
uh last week at the uh open source
security foundation um conference in
which
um you know with this this expansion and
growth of open source packages
currently um upwards about 30 30 of a
lot of those packages only have a single
maintainer in some cases none um so i'm
curious as far as what your insight into
why we're seeing sort of this increase
in the amount of time that it actually
takes to get some of these
vulnerabilities fixed once they are you
know discovered
well i guess one of the things to uh to
note here is that 49 days was back in
2018 and uh worked 110 now so over a
span of three years
we've just more than doubled
the amount of time it takes to fix
over that same period of time
two things have happened one
software use and development has been
growing at tremendous rates
and at the same time
when it comes to
open source software and security
security has become a far more important
topic now than it was back in 2018
not not even any any anywhere close to
uh
back in 2018 there was it was it was a
shadow of what it is today
so i think both of those things are um
significant factors here we're paying
much more attention to security uh as a
consequence there's more time that's
being spent on security we're much more
attuned to uh the concerns about
vulnerabilities
but one thing that's not so there's lots
more potentially that has to be fixed
these days because there's so much more
software so i think um
and we have resourcing issues when it
comes to actually software development
so i think all these things kind of
combined together is helping push the
time window out but one thing that is
good news is that if you look at the
criticality of these different kinds of
fixes that are being put in place the
really critical fixes are happening very
quickly but with an increased number of
fixes that are required to be addressed
some of those low like low priority ones
just aren't being addressed in atomic
fashion because of the resourcing issues
so i think that's part of the
explanation behind what's going on here
yep
yeah i mean i i i would have said
basically the the same thing that i
ironically you know this does it
actually exposes somewhat that we're
we're actually getting better at
detecting vulnerabilities um but uh but
clearly we you know we've got a a a
resourcing issue there in terms of uh
of of managing to solve
uh some of the lower um priority things
and you know i mean
open source is a is a broad church right
and for every huge well-funded project
like the linux kernel like kubernetes
you know there's this ten thousand
projects that are being run by you know
one person in their spare time and you
know prioritizing uh security fixes
particularly with things that that may
be perceived as as uh less less
important um you know versus versus use
of feature velocity and
and support and all the rest of the
things that that open source maintainers
have to have to do you know is uh is a
challenge
i mean i i suspect if we took some of
the uh if we looked at this across some
of the the biggest projects we would
actually find that the time scale is
very short to fix um
to fix vulnerabilities but when we look
at these things in in aggregate across
you know across a huge range of uh uh
earth projects of different sizes and
all the rest of it then you know we're
clearly gonna gonna see that uh that
resource issue that's at the uh that's
at the the base of of some of these
issues um
in terms of the uh the the fixing
vulnerabilities in open source
in the open source portion of
applications versus the the kind of
homegrown
portion of applications um
when we look at
a typically in most modern applications
that portion of open source is actually
far larger so you know
in in some ways that there's always
going to skew that skew that number um
somewhat
uh because you know 80 20 if
is it ends up being a typical split of
of people you know in in language
ecosystems using packages so
yeah
yeah and that's a very good point is
that there's probably more open source
than a lot of modern applications and
the fact that there's probably less
resources
there as well and i know that's a big
focus of the um open source security
foundation is to to promote more
community awareness and sharing and
collaborating and giving back and i
think those go hand in hand with with
potentially addressing and fixing some
of these these issues as we see sort of
more and more use right the ability to
actually handle those appropriately but
i think an insight of what you both just
shared how the critical ones being
handled and again there's disparity and
differences between you know potentially
some of the larger ones the ones that
are used a lot more often
this was an interesting finding um and
and i know like as far as um as we start
to talk about you know the the open
source uh first party code and some of
the other components a lot of these
applications
looking at some of the survey results as
far as you know what organizations were
using what what approaches that they
were taking and um one of the
interesting ones to see and i think this
is probably just more consistent than
what we've seen over the last few years
is the fact that you know sas static
application security testing software
composition analysis tools are still
ranked number one and number two in the
ability to address a lot of these um
security concerns um but i there also
seems to be a wide variety of different
approaches for um you know how
organizations are also starting to stack
releases either augmenting those or very
complementary approaches or just sort of
um additional techniques
of looking for those vulnerabilities so
curious as far as like again with with
the
industry interaction and and
organizations that you talk to if this
is in line with what you're seeing and
other thoughts that you might have on
approaches to actually you know help
address and um what we'll talk about a
little bit is actually automating some
of these approaches as far as helping
organizations address these risks
one of the things that kind of comes to
my mind here was that
is the whole
theory behind
doing sda
which is that doing it on a time-based
kind of principle it's probably not the
best approach
and so one of the challenges i think
that exists here in michigan to see if
mick or matt you have insight into that
is how to how to deal with sca and more
on in more of a real time or near
real-time kind of basis
um because there needs to be uh
when vulnerabilities become known there
needs to be sort of immediate potential
to take action on them
um and a time-based approach to being
that has a lot of latency built into it
it's probably not your friend when it
comes to trying to get some of these
vulnerabilities
yeah i mean i i think you know when we
talk about this whole landscape you know
there are there are
uh two
it's not just one challenge right we've
got this challenge of of the open source
supply chain having become
a a uh fertile place for attackers to
look for for for exploits but we've also
got in in general
um you know this
that organizations need to move towards
this you know what we call the developer
first security model right where you've
got to change the way you do security
from being like this kind of gatekeeper
function at the end through to something
that's integrated all the way through
your software development life cycle and
that's because you know velocity is
absolute key to success in in the modern
era and you know we can't treat security
in the same way that we used to so i
think um
you know seeing
uh
seeing organizations who've managed to
build into those multiple integration
points all the way through their
software development life cycle is is
you know a real key success metric for
people who are starting to get
how we really need to do this stuff and
you know to steve's point you know once
we've got those you know uh regular
tests on subsequent management systems
we're testing on every pr we're testing
in production you know all these all
these uh these integration points in the
sdlc have subtly different
reasons to do them right and you kind of
need to be thinking about doing all of
them because you know they they're
detecting different things so you know
uh giving developers access to tooling
where they can immediately see before
that code's even been checked in that
there are issues with a particular
dependency or issues with lines of code
that they've just written
you know is is absolutely critical the
cheapest place to fix anything is before
it's even been checked in right but then
you know having those integration points
into your source code management into
your ci cd pipeline you know
you need to be doing those things as
well so that you can you know you have
real-time updates on uh you know none of
this is fixed we're constantly on this
on this sliding floor of new
vulnerabilities being being
uh being found and and new exploits
every day so i i i think um you know
being able to integrate that stuff is is
where you start to get the most bang for
your buck from a security perspective
yeah i mean this goes back to something
i said earlier which is there's probably
about 10 fairly popular tool categories
when it comes to being able to address
uh security across the life cycle
and for instance you know i mentioned
iac tools and the value they have from
the standpoint of automation well there
are iac scanning tools to help you
ensure that the iac scripts that you're
running don't end up creating
additional headaches and they're
scanning tools also on policy tools for
cloud service providers uh being able to
check on the resources that you're
getting from them and whether or not
from a security standpoint they're where
they need to be
so
i think one of the things to take away
from this beyond what we just see here
on the screen is this is this notion of
take a look in the report uh to get a
sense of what those additional different
tool categories are and you know begin
to think about how they may be able to
also you know some of them add
significant value to what we're already
doing
and i think the uh the automation piece
of this is really key as well i mean
we did some work uh last year as part of
our cloud native security report where
we um
looked at uh
how automated um
uh
organizations deployment pipelines were
as a kind of proxy for how far along you
were on your your kind of journey
towards cloud native because you know
that's a very strong indicator if you
are doing end-to-end you know fully
automated deployments there are there
are um you know a whole set of things
that have to be in line there to to get
there so it's a fairly good proxy for
that and uh we saw very strong
correlation between uh folks with high
levels of deployment uh pipeline
automation
how easy it was for them to
implement uh security scanning tools
because you know you're fully automated
ci cd you've got lots of hook points
that are you know it's a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy in a sense that
it becomes much easier to to integrate
automation in there and then a a very
strong correlation between um uh that
and time to fix so a dramatic drop in
how long it was taking people to find
and fix vulnerabilities when they had
that automation in place all the way
through the sdlc
yeah the the automation i think is k
which i think is a good transition to
where we're going with this but the
automation and being able to take more
of a
proactive approach in a lot of these
types of circumstances not disregarding
um steve what you just mentioned which
is still the ability to have the
reactive component because those are
still very critical when you start
looking at open source and the dynamic
nature of which you know the the
vulnerabilities and risks change as as
as matt mentioned earlier right like
they the vulnerability and log4j had
been in there for quite a few years um
it just happened that it was discovered
um at a very specific time and then were
remediated and everybody had to take
action in order to follow up to ensure
that they you know were in line with
with a lot of those changes based upon
that that timing proactive giving you
more of the efficiencies but having
always the plan in place in order to
ensure that you're you know um
being able to react when the situation
does change
with that said
i think and these were some of the core
sort of components i think that you
could easily start to derive out of that
that report and there is again a lot
more extensive information steve just
alluded to that you know there's there's
a lot of data points that are in there
that are very interesting which have
probably stories behind them and some of
the intriguing elements that i think is
is useful to use we'll share the link
for the the full report here in just a
little bit from a takeaways perspective
i think one of the one of the more
prominent themes that we've seen um and
again these go hand in hand both
from a from a sneak perspective and as
well as an um linux foundation
perspective is you know encouraging
developers to improve their security
knowledge it's the the more that you can
take information and especially with
with you know the the larger
adoption and creation of applications
the explosion of applications uh the
more drive for rapid development
the more you can take that security
expertise and bundle it into some sort
of format within a workflow of the
developers starts to to empower them
right it allows to have some of those
secure coding best practices approaches
visibilities into risks
early in that decision making process
become more probably one of the more key
sort of approaches for being able to
address a lot of these security issues
as early as possible
hand in hand with that i think is you
know as we were just
you know discussing there's a lot of
sort of approaches and solutions that
you can start to leverage in order to
take that capability and actually
leverage it
within the pipeline within the pr checks
within the ide and so leveraging
solutions one of the other themes that
we haven't spent as much time
that i know is
that inside the report as well was this
data points that
a lot of the
individuals that were involved with the
survey also asked for more
vendor expertise to embed more sort of
security insight into controls to take
more ownership of that so that you know
there wasn't all of these pockets of
individual knowledge and that the
industry starts to take a lot of this
more responsibility on in order to help
promote that with those organizations
steve i don't know if you want to then
yeah no
that's absolutely correct that was one
of the key takeaways which was the
users were looking for more intelligent
tooling from the vendor community
um and it's not that the youth that the
users are trying to abdicate
responsibility and say well this
security issue is best solved by
somebody else because there's lots that
the user community should be doing
themselves
but i mean it's still a point well taken
which is more intelligent tooling and
integration between the different kinds
of tools uh would go a long way to be
able to have a better approach to how we
do to deal with security and probably
not at the expense of more time on the
part of the developers if the tools were
more intelligent and had better
integration
yeah
and that that was an interesting one to
see and then the last sort of key
takeaway i think that we've seen with
all of this goes in hand with kind of
the the first two approaches the more
that you can
empower and share and then start to
embed into a very proactive way but
doing so in an automated fashion right
automated automate automated build into
those
checks and matt discussed earlier is
looking at one of the ways that we
looked at that cloud native application
security um report last year was to look
at organizations that had reached that
maturity as sort of that that mechanism
or bar to say is you know are they more
mature because they have some of these
approaches this allows them to do way
more with less so the more i think that
you can embed
a lot of that capability in there it
allows you to have that that that speed
of innovation right this this is
probably one of the more core components
because that's
from a business perspective that's what
you're trying to achieve um and so being
able to achieve that speed of innovation
and the ability to create these
applications in a rapid fashion
but still ensure that the risk of the
security of the or the security of the
organization
is still being kept in check um i think
is a critical component that we're
seeing as far as a common theme here
excellent so with that said as we
mentioned earlier on this is uh there is
a link
to the
full report that you can download
there's a lot like i said a lot of
additional insight that you can derive
from that there's some summarization
that we share it you know early on the
report but then there's a lot of the
details and and again some of the the
cross-referencing that steve shared
earlier as far as you know what are some
of the differences of ones with policies
once without how did that impact some of
the other sort of server results and how
they map out so a lot of really great
insight that's in there um and you know
at sneak and i'm sure the linux
foundation as well
love the ability to entertain any any
questions matter of fact um i don't know
if we want to check the q a and see if
there's any
questions that are queued up um
and if so we can address those otherwise
we can
turn it back over to candice let's see
if there's
one in there i see
one question
centralized api registry ibm z16 may
increase the software
cyber security may have your view on
this um
matt or steve i don't have the
expertise on the api i'm not sure what
that's referring to i don't know all
right let's go and do some uh do some
research i'm assuming this is something
in ibm's portfolio so uh
yeah
i mean it is true that the z series has
a lot of unique capabilities that go
well beyond
what other platforms have been able to
accomplish
so
i don't know specifically about security
but i think
i'm not surprised uh given the nature of
the question that this suggests that ibm
is doing something relatively unique
here that probably has
for the mainframe customers some
significant added value
excellent so if there's no further
questions candace i will turn it back
over to you to
to wrap up
thank you so much mick and steve and
matt today um
and thank you everyone for